[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans votre 78 dans l'actualité
de ce jeudi 28 septembre des nouveaux
aménagements pour la ville de chantelou-
Les Vignes la commune a inauguré hier
mercredi 27 septembre le quartier des
petits pas des travaux qui s'inscrivent
dans le projet de la future cité
éducative Simon veille l'objectif
améliorer le cadre de vie des habitants
pas besoin d'aller jusqu'en Normandie ou
sur la côte atlantique en restant dans
les zvelines vous pouvez passer votre
permis bateau à Sartrouville l'école au
tout permis vous forme sur la scène
alors même si le fleuve secoue moins que
l'océan les élèves sont tout de même
motivés et puis le jeudi comme
d'habitude nous vous donnons nos idées
de sortie dans les yelines au programme
pour ce weekend le salon de l'art et de
l'habitat à la ferme du Mané un festival
de jeux de société à morpa ou encore un
festival sur la photographie à
rambouiller les détails en fin
d'émission en deème partie l'invité du
78 nous vous parlerons de la plus
ancienne foire de France qui est de
retour sur l'île des Impressionnistes à
Chatou vous avez jusqu'au dimanche 1er
octobre pour dénicher la bonne affaire
meubles tableau vaisselle on en parle
avec reméy Machard antiire et président
du syndicat professionnel du marché de
l'Antiquité
changement de visage pour le quartier de
la Noé à Chantelou les vignes après la
démolition d'un immeuble et de quelques
travaux de réaménagement urbain les
chantlouva pourront bientôt profiter de
la nouvelle place des petits pas ce sera
un lieu qui sera extrêmement vert avec
65 arbres nouveaux on a besoin d'ilau de
fraîcheur l'idée c'est vraiment de
proposer de l'ombre des endroits où on
peut s'asseoir des endroits où on peut
s'apaiser et des endroits où on peut un
peu profiter de l'été sinon c'est un peu
c'est un peu compliqué conçu pour
améliorer la qualité de vie des
habitants la place des petits pas
donnera aussi accès à la future cité
éducative Simone veille qui débutera ses
travaux en 2024 puisqu'on va regrouper
collège et écoles élémentaires sur un
même site de façon à ce que la rupture
de l'entré en 6e qui est terrible pour
les enfants et en particulier dans ces
grandes cités soit amorti par la
coexistence dans un même ensemble qui
est la cité éducative donc c'est à la
fois un projet urbain au sens du béton
mais c'est aussi un projet humain
l'urbain étant au service de l'humain la
cité éducative Simone veille ouvrira ses
portes en
[Musique]
2028 c'est une
autorité titionnel qui a été créé en
2011 et qui vise à défendre les droits
des citoyens et des citoyennes face au
dysfonctionnement qu'on peut connaître
au quotidien notamment avec les services
publics vous avez aussi une compétences
liées à tout ce qui va concerner la
lutte contre les discriminations donc là
ça peut concerner toutes les entreprises
publiques comme privé la défense des
droits de l'enfant et de leur intérêt
supérieur une 4è mission consiste à
accpagner les citoyens et les citoyennes
face aux éventuels manquements
déontologie des forces de police police
au sens
large tous les citoyens tous les
citoyennes toutes aussi des entreprises
des association si elles estiment que
dans leur droit il y a une difficulté
c'est un service public gratuit
confidentiel et totalement impartial
c'est ce qu'on entend par autorité
administrative indépendante on est un
des dépendant des pouvoirs politiques ou
économiques en
place c'est effectivement un événement
qu'on organise maintenant c'est la 6e
édition qui est un événement qui se veut
place publique alors donc on a décidé
les vendredi et samedi prochain donc les
29 et 30 septembre de s'installer à
trappe place des merisers place du
marché donc pas de rendez-vous c'est
tout l'intérêt de la démarche c'est
justement d'aller vers les personnes qui
dans leur quoti pourrait rencontrer des
difficultés au lieu d'attendre c'est
aussi une démission qu'on remplit mais
au lieu d'attendre dans nos bureaux que
la saisine
[Musique]
arrive la conférence sur l'abolition de
la chasse aura bien lieu dans les
ivelines organisé dans un premier temps
à rambouiller fief de la chasse en
Île-de-France ce rendez-vous avait
suscité la polémique et avait dû être
annulé finalement le photographe et
militant écologiste yanartthus Bertrand
ouvre ses studios m nul pour accueillir
l'intervention la conférence aura lieu
demain vendredi et affiche déjà complet
ce matin attrape l'entreprise FV
spécialisé dans le développement des
motorisations a organisé une journée
portes ouvertes sur son site partenaire
privilégié des acteurs majeurs de
l'industrie du transport français FV a
montré toute l'évolution de son offre
située dans les Yvelines l'entreprise
possède un emplacement stratégique une
implantation qui permet d'être à
proximité de nos clients de leur offrir
toutes les activités de service de
support de projeter nos équipes sur site
client pour les accompagner
et ça sur le spectre complet tel que je
l'évoqué du développement power train de
l'électrification et du véhicule au
programme petit-déjeuner visite guidé
accompagné du Mouvement des Entreprises
de France des Yvelines l'objectif était
de promouvoir ses activités sur le
territoire ivelinois on est toujours
attentif à ces entreprises qui sont
aussi bah confronté à un certain nombre
de de problématiques et on veut en tout
cas que les ivelines restent attractif
ce samedi 30 septembre les restos du
cœur des ivelines organise un concert
caritatif à Oudan l'association vous
donne rendez-vous dès 18h30 dans la
salle des fêtes de la commune au
programme Melet de Jaz et de musique
classique interprété par un quitureur de
saxophoniste ce moment de convivialité
permettra de vrai pour les plus démunis
vous pouvez réserver vos places dès
maintenant début septembre les restau du
cœur avaient alerté le gouvernement sur
les graves difficultés financières
traversées par
[Musique]
l'association
alors je viens mettre la clé hop le
contact je m'assure que le coupe circuit
est bien en place donc là on est bon
c'est un cours de conduite un peu
particulier dans lequel ces deux élèves
s'apprêtent à s'embarquer depuis 2020
l'école au tout permis permet aux
francilien des 16 ans de passer leur
permis bateau dans les ivelines une
formation qui a le vent en poupe au
commandes de l'établissement Matth
Weldon ancien pompier et sauvteur en mer
une fois que la formation théorique est
faite il a examen théorique à passer et
une fois qu'on a validé l'examen
théorique donc on fait la formation
pratique et on a les différents
objectifs à valider place à la pratique
pour nos élèves du jour c'est parti pour
3h30 de navigation et de manœuvre au
rythme de la scène hop faire comme ça ça
ça marche aussi il y a pas de
problème alors du coup on va pouvoir se
mettre en marche
avant voilà la gâchette on pousse vers
l'avant nickel hop on va pouvoir trouver
régime moteur à 1300 tours là on est
actuellement à 700 tours minute première
épreuve après la prise en main passer en
sécurité sous un pont une manœuvre
courante pour la navigation fluviale
moins facile qu'elle en à l'air piéger
voilà nickel au fil de l'eau et des heur
les manœuvres s'enchaînent tout ça dans
un cadre unique entre Sartrouville et
Montesson c'est vrai que le cadre est
plutôt idylique le coin est intéressant
alors tout comme sur un fleuve au final
on va avoir du courant on va avoir des
vents euh qui peuvent d'ailleurs
tourbillonner toute la journée donc on
peut avoir un vent qui vient d'une
direction et qui très rapidement vient
vient de l'autre donc au final on arrive
à bien comprendre le principe du bateau
c'est-à-dire on est soumis au vent
soumis au courant des forces dominantes
qui vont agir sur nous et au final nous
permettre bien d'êre efficace dans la
navigation par la suite c'est agréable
puis c'est surtout très pratique parce
que quand on habite la région faut bien
pouvoir passer ça sur un fleuve sur la
sur n'importe quel espace dont on
dispose pour cette formation comptée
entre 300 et 420 € il ne reste plus qu'à
souhaiter bon vent au nouveau
[Musique]
battelier
festive photo est un festival qui existe
depuis 2010 et qui se qui se passe tous
les 2 ans à rambouiller cette année le
parrain c'est Yan Artus
Bertrand on y voit 1500 photos qui sont
réparties dans divers lieux de
rambouillé ce festival va se dérouler ce
weekend à partir de vendredi et il se
terminera donc dimanche sur 3 jours il
se déroule dans divers lieux de
rambouiller donc la Bergerie Nationale
vous y verrez 1500 photos et s'il y
avait une seule photo qu'il ne faut pas
rater c'est la photo de TOMY crossetta
la panthère noire avec des yeux d'un
verre éclatant vous pourrez arpenter des
lieux gratuits mais l'entrée du festival
c'est de 10 € par personne et les
familles 20
[Musique]
€.
demain matin nous devrions toujours
avoir un beau soleil dans les evvelines
au niveau des températures ça monte
légèrement il fera 18°gr à versaill et
rouillé et 19° à Mantel jolie et oudant
demain après-midi le soleil sera
toujours présent côté température il
fera 21 à 23° en moyenne sur l'ensemble
du département et pour les prévisions
météo de ce weekend elles sont
semblables à celles de cette semaine le
ciel sera dégagé samedi il fera environ
9°gr le matin et 20°gr l'après-midi et
dimanche nous aurons un temps estival
avec un grand soleil côté température il
fera 11°gr le matin et 25° l'après-midi
tout de suite l'invité du 78 avec
Gabriel
Gontier
depuis le 22 septembre la Foire
Internationale de Chatou est de retour
sur l'île des impressionniste la plus
ancienne foire de France revient pour
une 105e édition Rémy Machard bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président du snsao
GA le comité organisateur de la foire de
châou également exposant on imagine que
vous attendiez ce retour avec impatience
on attend toujours la foire de château
avec impatience c'est un grand
rendez-vous pour les professionnels qui
viennent de la France entière qui
viennent parfois de de l'étranger des
Belges des Italiens et puis les
visiteurs aussi attendent le retour de
cet événement avec impatience qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont avoir la chance de découvrir
ces visiteurs pendant la dizaine de
jours où se tient la foire alors la
foire de Chatou c'est vraiment
l'expression de toutes les ambiances
autour de que peuvent présenter les
professionnels tous les tous les
courants
artistiques de l'Antiquité jusqu'au
vintage donc vous pourrez rencontrer
vraiment toutes les grands courants
artistiques de notre histoire et de
notre culture une des forces de la foire
c'est tout ce qu'il y a d'exposé ici
c'est une foire qui se tient pour la
105e édition c'est un un événement
historique qu'est-ce qui fait que ça
continue de marcher dans le temps bah
c'est une institution et puis comme je
vous l'ai dit les professionnels ont
besoin de de s'exprimer de
présenter leur le leurs œuvres leur
leurs belles pièces leurs beaux objets
et puis de rencontrer le public c'est ça
le succès de de Chatou c'est c'est une
ambiance particulière qui qui est très
attendue et qui est nécessaire à notre
profession et qui est pour laquelle le
public est en attente vous
personnellement en tant que exposant
qu'est-ce qu'elle représente cette foire
de châou c'est un moment important dans
l'année à l'automne et au printemps ce
sont deux grands rendez-vous et bien sûr
comme comme les autres professionnels je
réserve des pièces exclusivement pour la
Foire de Chatou on a demandé aux
exposants de la foire ce que
représentait la foire de châou je vous
propose qu'on les écoute c'est le
rendez-vous pour nous les marchand deux
fois par an on est content de tous se
retrouver ici à foire de Chatou il y a
une super ambiance la foire de Chatou
pour moi déjà c'est un souvenir aussi un
peu d'enfance parce que je venais là
plus petit avec mes parents je suis venu
là quand j'étais aussi je suis toujours
collectionneur maintenant je suis
marchand euh pour moi c'est beaucoup de
choses on va dire la foire de château
mais il y a surtout quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est que il y a de moins
en moins de foir aussi en région
parisienne aux antiires donc ça permet
concentrer aussi un certain nombre de
personnes c'est le plus joli rendez-vous
qu'on puisse trouver qui est biannuel et
qui en plus est local pour moi parce que
je suis 30 minutes d'ici à
crépière donc sans boutique mais donc
justement la foire c'est l'occasion de
montrer un petit peu tout ce qu'on a
dans la maison alors réy Macha on
retrouve cette année encore les
exposants historiques il y a également
des nouveaux exposants tous les ans oui
chaque année il y a il y a un
renouvellement d'une partie des
exposants alors vous savez la foire de
Chatou c'est c'est un événement qui est
attendu par les professionnels et donc
il y a des gens qui sont là depuis
vraiment la toute première édition on a
on a des des des anciens qui ne peuvent
pas se se pass se passer de de
l'ambiance festive de Chatou et puis euh
pour une autre
catégorie d'exposants c'est-à-dire les
plus jeunes c'est un challenge de de
réussir à à exposer à la foire de Chatou
et cette année en particulier nous avons
de très jeunes exposants et nous en
sommes très fiers puisque le
SNCAO vient de créer le prix Marcus donc
le prix Marcus c'est le prix du jeune
marchand acteur du patrimoine que nous
organisons sous le parrainage de Stéphan
Bern et qu'il et qui sera remis au mois
de décembre à au lauréat et il y a
quelques lauréat qui sont ici présents
et puis il y a des jeunes marchand pour
lesquels c'est la première édition en
terme de tranche d'âge vous avez une
idée du plus jeune et du plus vieux dans
les marchands oh je crois que ça va de
25 ans à
5 6 7 ans voilà oui c'est très large
c'est très large comme finalement les
objets qu'on retrouve aussi il y a de
nombreux objets d'exception est-ce queil
y en a qui ont particulièrement attiré
votre attention alors il y en a plein en
les a vu mais est-ce qu'il y en a
quelques-uns qui ont plus attiré votre
attention écoutez il y a toujours
tellement de de de belles surprises de
de beaux objets que je je ne pourrais
pas me focaliser sur un seul alors plein
d'objets on l'a compris il y a déjà eu
des ventes exceptionnel bien sûr il y en
a tous les ans dans les objets dans les
œuvres d'art dans le mobilier il a du
mobilier absolument exceptionnel de de
tous les
âges de tous les styles oui oui il y a
eu des des belles ventes qui se sont
déjà passées ce weekend et mais
rassurez-vous il y a encore énormément
de choses à découvrir énormément de de
de choses qui qui qui attendent une
nouvelle maison vous qui connaissait
très bien la foire comment est-ce qu'on
fait des bonnes affaires de façon
générale sur la foire on ne peut faire
que des bonnes affaires vous savez j'ai
une formule qui dit que la le marché de
l'Antiquité le marché de l'art chez nous
à Chatou c'est la première classe au
prix de la seconde donc il faut savoir
que chaque objet par rapport à sa valeur
intrinsèque finalement est à un prix
très bas alors il y a des experts qui
sont présents sur la foire d'une part
d'une part pour contrôler ce qui est
exposé mais aussi pour pour aider les
acheteurs c'est ça c'est exactement ça
alors cette année nous avons un collège
de C experts un expert généraliste en
bijou en art tribal en art contemporain
ce qui fait que ces experts sont à la
disposition du public dans un premier
temps il renseigne les marchands il
clarifie les descriptions et puis
pendant toute la durée de la foire ils
sont à la disposition du public et moi
je conseille de faire appel à l'expert
ou aux
experts avant de prendre une décision
pour un gros achat alors la foire de
Chatou ça fait le plaisir des chineurs
des passionnés d'art mais c'est aussi
destiné au simples curieux qui ont envie
de découvrir bien sûr la foire de châou
c'est un musée à ciel ouvert donc on
vient à Chatou aussi pour se cultiver
pour acquérir des connaissances
d'ailleurs la la plus grande partie de
notre profession consiste à transmettre
bien sûr du patrimoine mais également
des con
alors reméi Machard dernière question
pour ceux qui ne sont pas encore décidés
à avoir franchi les portes de la Foire
des châoux pourquoi il faut venir bah il
faut venir parce que c'est un lieu
magique on peut avoir le syndrome de
Florence on peut se régaler les yeux on
peut acquérir de très belles choses ou
de choses simples mais belle et
authentique pour agrémenter son
intérieur merci r Mach d'avoir été avec
nous d'avoir à nos questions merci
Gabriel la foire de Chatou c'est
jusqu'au 1er octobre de 10h à 19h et
vous attendez tout le monde les
passionnés d'art mais aussi les simples
curieux les passionnés d'art et les
simples curieux qui auront de toute
façon des envies et bien rendez-vous sur
l'île des Impressionnistes en attendant
très belle soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78